it's true that you could use a normal
resolution image in the source and then
replace it with JavaScript with a higher
resolution image when you
programmatically detect the device pixel
ratio is greater than 1 however this
means that you would be downloading the
normal image and then a high density
image on all high density devices and
unfortunately most of the current high
density devices that is where device
pixel ratio is set higher to one our
mobile devices like my phone in my
tablet or bandwidth is probably at a
premium so this isn't really a good
solution for any reason except
simplicity it is possible though that
this will be solved on the server side
for the device pixel ratio scenario
particularly by something called client
hints client hints is a header sent to
the server to let it know what device
pixel ratio you're rendering at and what
size you're actually looking for it uses
the very header to let it know that the
version shouldn't be reused by caches
improperly however client hints isn't
broadly implemented and deployed yet and
this approach won't necessarily solve
everything about responsive images
however once this approach is actually
implemented broadly it will definitely
be a great tool for fixing density
issues for now though you need to make
the decisions on the client side and ask
the server for the right image for your
device pixel ratio except remember it's
not just device pixel ratio